走上有300万的存款，
自己又能一年挣10万块钱，
老公一年还能挣100万块钱，
老公也没说逼着你生二胎，
这种情况用英语怎么说呢？
就Enjoy，
好好的享受你的当下，
你的这个状态是多少人梦寐以求的状态了，
有点不知道怎么说，
你能不能你问我，
那你结婚了吗？
结婚了一三年，
到现在已经有十二三年，
有小孩吗？
有一个几岁了，
现在十岁，
男孩女孩呀，
男孩儿，
那你现在遇到的困惑是两口子的关系啊，
还是公公婆婆的关系啊，
还是工作上的关系啊，
孩子夫妻之间的关系了，
加上现在考虑要不要二胎子的问题，
夫妻之间是她有伤害过你吗？
干了什么伤害家庭的事儿吗？
现在的话我没有发现，
现在你手上有多少存款呢？
存款的话，
我们都是共同的，
应该是有个300多吧，
那现在是你想要二胎还是她想要要二胎呢？
我感觉她也想要，
我这边也想要，
但是有一个情况，
现在我就是你要了二胎谁帮忙带呢？
我婆婆，
我第一胎一直都是婆婆带的，
和婆婆相处的怎么样呢？
婆婆相处的还可以，
但是因为某些事情，
现在就感觉就没有之前的关系那么好了，
就心里有隔阂，
那你们两口子主要靠谁挣钱呢？
我老公我自己这边也有收入，
可以养活我自己，
你大概一年挣多少呀西？
左右，
那挺好的，
那他大概一年挣多少啊，
100个左右，
那你现在心里介意的点是什么呢？
之前的时候我们因为中间差了10岁也要做啊，
但是我们两个就不知道身体原因还是什么原因，
一直虽然流产，
但是通过这个事情可查的，
也就是说是我们两个的是有些原因，
如果说想要二胎的话，
需要去做治疗，
但是我老公就是说顺其自然，
又过了好多年之后，
去年的时候我也问过她的问题，
我们平时聊天的时候干嘛的时候，
他就说也想有二胎这个打算，
但是我去年的时候我问他要不要要这个二胎，
当时没有说，
过了两三天的时候，
他后跟我说，
他说现在不考虑要，
本来你们就是一个小男孩，
十岁了，
对不对，
对，
他说这事咱有啥妈妈委屈呢，
要和不要不就两口子商量个事儿吗？
要不要咱这日子不都挺好过的吗？
我觉得也挺好怪的，
但是我现在还想再要一个，
因为现在36岁了，
再不要的话，
我再听过脑力看能也要不了，
现在我就想再尝试一下，
现在他那头呢，
很积极吗？
现在那我问过他，
他说综合考虑之前的时候身体原因没有要，
现在也不一定能要上，
再加上她说我们现在两个也没有精力再去养个孩子，
我觉得现在36岁还可以，
但是我听到她这个答案的话，
我们两个也没有继续沟通，
我感觉是这样啊，
如果说习惯性流产流了几次啊，
两次。
留了两次，
而且你们也没有这个时间精力去配合，
去健身啊，
去营养搭配，
他也没有这个心思去配合你吗？
那我就别让自己那么遭罪了呗，
又不是说他逼着我要生二胎，
我现在这个状态，
孩子都10岁了，
我36岁，
我好好的经营自己的身体健康，
皮肤容貌，
经营自己的心理，
让自己每天都高高兴兴的，
开开心心的，
这日子多好过，
咋想的呢？
你又不是说他特别想要，
不得已配合他是吧，
他那头都没有说特别积极，
特别想要了，
咋想的呢？
我他这边不想要的原因可能是我之前也有这个顾虑，
因为我的妈妈就是是因为那一个什么去世了，
我舅舅也是，
所以他可能考虑到这个原因，
也不想再要一个，
我之前的时候也是这样考虑了，
但是我想如果说我觉得你36，
他46，
他不想要也很正常了，
他35他比我小一岁，
我就想着要一个孩子，
如果说后期离婚的话会好一些，
我都不知道你这个就是逻辑了，
这怎么有这样的逻辑呢？
就但是需要问自心理咨询，
孩子要提逻咨询，
我现在你的这个状态已经是大家梦寐以求的状态了，
第一，
老公最起码说没有抓到实锤证据，
没有抓到实锤证据就当没有是吧，
没有做过什么伤害你的事情，
第二，
孩子健健康康的十岁了，
而且是个男孩儿，
第三，
手上有300万的存款，
第四，
自己又能一年挣十万块钱，
第五。
老公一年还能挣100万块钱，
第6，
老公也没说逼着你生二胎，
没有人逼着你生二胎，
这种情况用英语怎么说呢？
就Enjoy，
好好的享受你的当下，
你的这个状态是多少人梦寐以求的状态了，
我可能现在也是在胡思乱想，
我就想着要不要离婚，
不离的话要不要生孩子，
但是吧，
你这个真的是咱们啊掏心窝测的想真的是需要一些心理干预，
因为你这没有任何离婚的必要和契机呀，
好好的日子不知道好好过呀，
我妈妈是癌症去世了嘛，
我舅舅也是，
这不是不想生孩子的一个点，
他会不会后妻，
如果说我们两个离婚的话，
他再结婚，
他是不是可以自己再要孩子，
你不能去恶意揣测别人啊，
你不能先把别人当成个人犯啊，
就某种程度上的话，
人家不想你再流产，
不想你再做试管，
人家可能也是考虑到不想让你死的早呢，
你们家有癌症的这个那个啊，
他不想你有癌症的风险啊，
那人家这个不是往好了想啊，
但是我这样会不被加了害你又不是说没给他生孩子，
你已经给他生了一个男孩了，
你耽误他什么了？
他又不是特别积极想要生，
你耽误他啥了？
一点没耽误啊，
你们现在是一个完美的状态呀，
圆满的状态啊，
你耽误他啥了？
可能自己天天想的太多了，
挂个心理方面的号去看看心理医生，
你现在生活很圆满啊，
孩子平安健康，
男孩10岁了。
老公又能挣钱，
好，
我知道了，
谢谢老好，
就这样啊，
拜拜啊，
记得点赞关注哦。